a united front
iran and russia long-time allies both
say
they want u.s sanctions against iran
lifted talks between the remaining
members of the 2015 nuclear deal
iran china france germany russia and the
united kingdom
are set to resume in vienna on thursday
but there was a warning from foreign
minister javad zarif
we talked in venana to restore the
rights of our people and end
sanctions but these talks have a limited
time europe and america's time to return
to their commitments under the jcpoa
is very limited and if they lose this
opportunity
they will face unfavorable conditions
russia called on all parties to return
to the deal
we understand our partners in tehran are
ready to move forward immediately on
this issue
provided the u.s takes the appropriate
steps we support the ongoing
negotiations in vienna
and condemn any attempt to undermine
these important talks
an attack on iran's main nuclear
facility in the city of natanz on sunday
that left it blacked out has increased
tensions
both inside and outside the country and
are expected to affect the talks
conservative politicians in iran never
supported the 2015 nuclear deal in the
first place
many are now calling on president hassan
rouhani to end negotiations following
sunday's incident at iran's main nuclear
facility
this adds to the pressure for the
negotiating team and sets a time frame
with the current government leaving
office in august
russia condemned what it said were
attempts to undermine the negotiations
the extent of the damage at the natanz
nuclear facility is becoming more
apparent
the event that happened on sunday
relating to an electricity grid
destroyed a great deal of our enrichment
capabilities
several thousand centrifuges are now out
of service
the government blamed israel for what it
called sabotage
and issued this warning we will
retaliate for the attack on natanz at
all levels
at the proper time with similar
magnitude we won't allow our enemies to
reach their political objectives
iran says it will now enrich uranium to
60
that's 40 higher than it already is and
around 56 percent higher
than permitted in the nuclear deal but
all eyes are on vienna
with many sides hoping that despite the
incident at natanz
there can still be a breakthrough assad
beg al-jazeera thereon